foreign
so this is [__] wild have you seen
this Rogan the Rogan thing is Rogan like
the Rogan dad thing
the Rogan dad thing okay so let me set
this up oh yeah yeah I did you know what
this showed up on my thing and I
I brushed it off to the side and I never
got around to uh bringing it up but yeah
this is like his family is trying to
like
here you go tell this I just shaking
them down or something lied about me
your father if you lied about your
father what do you will you give you
give up the world
so that's his fight now
well my mom and my stepdad are actually
very happy yeah and they've been happy
since I was seven years old it's real
weird all my damage [__] came from My
real father so long before you were
seven yeah before I was seven that's all
the damaging [__] my father My real
father was crazy he was like a psychotic
person really yeah he was be beat the
[__] out of my mind now remember
something I will say this
broken is saying is when he before he
was seven
do you wonder if sometimes stuff like
that is implanted by a mom who's angry
at a dad and you know what I mean like
I've heard yeah I'm not saying that's
what happened I'm just saying that some
I've I've heard I've seen it let's put
it to you that way you know yeah because
like when I was a kid I actually saw my
dad right of course people you know what
I mean I wasn't implanted
um but you know I've also seen stories
of other people that
I just didn't believe it about them it
was like I don't know this feels like
kind of [__] but yeah
my cousin really yeah when he was five
yeah there you go he picked my cousin up
by his hair dude no no no no no my
cousin had done something he had hurt
somebody he was playing hard and hurt
somebody and he was a bigger kid he was
like 16. yeah and my dad picked him up
by his [__] hair I'll never forget
okay so he saw it happen so that yeah
that's not an implant that was that was
him actually seeing it happen I guess
that's the so anyway let's see what his
dad says
your father if you lied about your
father what do you will you give you
give up the world tired of it Joe I just
had enough if you can't talk to me face
to face you're a punk ass that's all you
are you got all the money I feel like I
believe Joe yeah I mean we'll see but
that I'm starting to believe Joe here
right but you know what you don't have
you don't have no heart and I'm going to
tell you something else you don't have
you ain't got two balls
damn damn no it's true when he was five
he fell off his bike
your father because you couldn't handle
me 81 years old you couldn't handle this
guy right here and when you wait you
weren't 81 years old when the thing he
said happened though right said I beat
up kids I beat up other women Joe
Harrison was when you fall
you fought your house ain't no next door
how could I get away with that my real
father was crazy he was like a psychotic
person ready to beat the [__] out you
know he sounds kind of crazy yeah you
owe me a big apology Joe you were taken
away at a very young age okay
unfortunately you did not get to grow up
with the man that we were fortunate
enough to grow up with that my kids are
fortunate enough to grow up with Max
women lots of [__] out of kids when he
went to college for acting he had to
take up drama it beats the [__] out of
him so I went from living around these
Italian New Jersey Psychopaths 70
Italians in North Jersey
word psychotic
yes
um I'm gonna have to back up Rogan on
this one
yeah yeah it seemed because he see he's
saying that you're a crazy old man with
a bad temper and then what you're
showing me
um this crazy old man with a bad temper
it's Joe Rogan and Joey Diaz have the
same father
I'm tiny crazy ass Italian psychopath
why is Kurt Metzger there what's
happening
that's Italians over here you know what
we know one thing for sure we know
family we're not caught up in the
[__] over there in Hollywood and all
that bro we're down to real Roots okay
and this man is the real rude brother
Joe is that Joe Rogan's brother Joe uh
show Rogan's half brother Joe
what you doing man
[__] on the other side of the table my
man no cameras no nothing bro and not me
don't worry I won't be here I'm sorry
that all this happened to you from the
bottom of my heart is that Joe's
half-sister
I I guess he's got a bunch of Italian
[__] head Guido half [__] yeah
half family that probably all want some
of that Rogan book so that's what this
is about right it's got to be the road
of money right I am sorry because you
will never know what you have missed out
on in life I love when I see the car
yeah he's doing pretty good
Royce yeah Marsh watch this part okay
here we go comments they just want the
money they want the money back I have a
box
Pandora's Box and if I open it Joe
things would get really ugly but see we
don't roll that way a psychopath for New
Jersey are you doing yourself a
psychopath and an extorting joke no is
she is she extorting him yes this feels
like extortion a Time cycle Italian
somebody's calling the old man jokumia
Michael pass whether or not you like
he's three-quarters Italian whether or
not he likes her I don't know but you
better look in the mirror real quick
it's about time you become a man Joe and
get to reality
you were wrong you lied we all know you
lied so everybody's mindful on something
okay you're looking at a real cop real
Detective
so now they're gonna tool them up hold
on wait a second let me get this
straight first they're extorting him now
they're gonna the cops are gonna tool
them up you're not gonna judge you'll
[__] you up
okay this record is squeaky clean let's
just get that in perspective Joe in
front of everybody I'm looking at you
and I'm pointing at you how are you from
North Jersey in a Steelers fan I'm here
sit down and me and you talk that's it
I won't tell nobody what was said I'm a
stand-up guy ain't like you making up
stories so I can make money
I don't do that [__] especially family I
don't do that but I'm going to tell you
something Joe
before you go here and you come here and
you sit I don't think go by that said
the ball the man that don't have their
fathers
why is this guy keep doing this with his
hands I don't know what's
going on here Joe Rogan's family is
[__] bizarre man well I mean he's
kind of weird so that makes sense he
said they can only sit beside them one
more last time I know that's me coming
out here just trying to connect this
selflessly brother tell you what I
believe in Joe
fam yo no disrespect
but you're beautiful
I like that he's like yeah and uh Joe I
want to meet you face to face I want to
talk without all the cameras before you
come here go get some [__] balls you
[__] it's like I don't think he's gonna
go you're not good at extending these
invites and let me tell you something my
father
Joe your mother was a [__] we all know
it
tell you what I believe in Joe family is
everything everybody else you meet you
think you're on Broadway you think
you're the this you take your dad I
don't think he's on a Broadway show
everybody else is a bus ride you get on
and you get off but family is it's only
here they barked at me marked at me
marked at me I'm barking back Joe you
know what you're gonna see
you're gonna see the real me your real
father now
I'm no joke our families that were very
very close no matter what I hate her the
most I think family it is always stayed
within our family the Familia
this whole
Joe Amelia saying something very new to
us this is the only way
yeah you look like you're handling it in
a very new fashion like you're timid
yeah to respond to him because we've
we've we've contacted him privately he
doesn't want to hear what we have to say
he doesn't want to hear a story he
doesn't want to hear the truth but
here's the thing
when you make an accusation
you have to back it up with proof and
when there's no proof there's no truth
to what you're saying
so we have a box
they have a box full of proof we have
proof from the Attorney General's office
Pandora's Box proof of the Attorney
General's office yeah proof from the
police department we have proof from
legal cases ever you said my father's a
psychopath
my father be children my father beat
women my father beat your mother
we have proof Joe that it never happened
we'll prove how could you legal prove
that it didn't where's your proof my
father okay show the proof wants is 25
minutes alone and 25 million dollars
with you no cameras nobody around and
Joe do me a favor when we meet
bring your report card from the college
you went to the drama school I know you
had to pass that test that's two parts
bro you're really leaning hard on this
drama joke
it's you're like talking about it too
much look man are you sure so they want
to be famous they want money I mean
that's it that's that's all I know I
don't have because this all comes from
one little clip of jets I like Joe made
a career of bashing his father no I mean
you know and you could tell from that
clip like that's when Rogan used to do
it like in his house
that was 11 years ago yeah probably one
where he thought not many people were
even gonna see it you know
I kind of believe Joe though that old
man seems insane yeah he does